s'intéresse à cette prise de parole
celle de volodymyr zelensky qui savaient
ce lundi à l'union africaine depuis kiev
le président ukrainien doit interpeller
aujourd'hui le bureau de la conférence
des chefs d'état africains ainsi que les
ambassadeurs africains accrédités auprès
de l'institution c'est la première fois
enclenché d'état ukrainien s'exprime
devant lui a alors que le président en
exercice macky sall 1 s'est rendu en
russie il y à peu on en parle avec vous
côtier ravinsky bonjour on était censé
pour tout vous dire ou faire vivre en
direct cette prise de parole qui se vaut
finalement à huis clos c'est cela pour
quoi alors où on peut se perdre en
conjectures mais tout de même il ya
quelque chose à remarquer c'est que vous
savez très bien que votre business qui
le président ukrainien lorsqu'il prend
la parole n'hésite pas à contrer c'est
un euphémisme ses interlocuteurs alors
reprocher des choses ça a été le cas
avec la france pour les armes ça a été
le cas avec l'allemagne également pour
les armées pour le louvoiement politique
donc comme on dit d'habitude il y va du
prix se prive pas de rentrer dans le
lard pardonnez moi l'expression de ses
interlocuteurs est ce que les dirigeants
de l'union africaine et macky sall en
premier ont jugé qu'une interview
publique plutôt qu'une à quai à un
échange public risquait de leur être
dommageable que peut dire zelensky qui
froisse les chefs d'état africains
précisément que les chefs de d'état
africains via macky sall se sont rendus
à moscou pour demander à vladimir
poutine que les questions de céréales ou
de d'approvisionnement en engrais soient
résolus autrement dit que tout ça soit
hors sanction est donc ça s'adresse
aussi aux européens et aux occidentaux
en général et que les russes fassent en
sorte par exemple que le blé ukrainien
ne soit plus bloquée précisément par le
dispositif militaire que les russes ont
instauré ont bâti dans la mer noire qui
empêche donc les exportations les
débouchés maritimes du blé ukrainien est
donc de faire en sorte que c'est surtout
ça qui est le plus important que
l'afrique ne soient pas frappés de plein
fouet par cette pénurie en céréales et
en engrais et surtout par l'augmentation
des cours et donc des coûts qui est vous
savez depuis le début de cette guerre à
ses conseillers pourquoi cette
dépendance de l'afrique vis-à-vis des
céréales une craignaient notamment alors
c'est ça qui est intéressant parce que
on pourrait dire finalement tout cela ne
peut pas pousser en afrique et donc il y
à une dépendance vis-à-vis des
importations or l'afrique a tout ce
qu'il faut pour faire pousser le blé
certains ont déjà commencé que ce soit
l'ethiopie ou le kenya et vous avez donc
des dispositions naturelles on va dire
biologique à produire ce type de
céréales comme le blé et pour les
engrais aussi il ya tout ce qu'il faut
dans le sous sol africain alors
évidemment il ya des difficultés
difficulté c'est d'abord que parfois les
cours des mêmes matières premières
occidental joue en quelque sorte du
dumping c'est à dire qu'ils ont un effet
déloyale sur les les cours africain mais
le plus important c'est que finalement
la politique la volonté politique dans
certains états pas tous les ans certains
états africains manquent et on le voit
particulièrement à un exemple qui est
celui des infrastructures structures
routières qui précisément permettent
d'échanger ce blé elles sont très
largement défaillante et quand bien même
vous auriez des productions très
conséquente de blé si vous n'arrivez pas
à les écouler d'une manière ou d'une
autre par des infrastructures routières
fiable et bien ça ne sert à rien donc
voyez il ya un problème intra africain à
cette affaire qui n'est pas forcément à
mettre en la déchargeant goût d'un
accusé les chefs d'état africains mais
il ya aussi parfois le résultat d'une
mauvaise gouvernance et qui n'est pas
axé justement sur un débouché qui
pourrait permettre à l'afrique d'être en
autosuffisance alimentaire et donc ne
plus être le jouet des cours en cas de
crise majeure dans le monde c'est pour
ça que l'afrique finalement se sent
concernée par le conflit oui oui elle se
sent concerné et avec une double option
si vous voulez 7 c'est finalement ce
petit manque cette dépendance vis-à-vis
des coûts
généreuse dans le monde et plus
particulièrement vis-à-vis de l'ukraine
et de la russie oblige l'afrique
finalement à se mettre en deçà de ce
conflit c'est à dire à s'interdire une
action ou un jugement politique alors
qu'on sait très bien que l'afrique les
états africains aspirent et ce tout à
fait légitime avoir un rôle éminent sur
la scène internationale mais vu cette
dépendance ils sont en retrait ils sont
obligés en quelque sorte de louvoyer et
de dire à vladimir poutine ou de dire en
tous les cas à la communauté
internationale nous ne sommes pas
certains que vladimir poutine soit
l'agresseur ça a été le cas lorsqu'il ya
eu des votes à l'onu où les états
africains se sont abstenus et donc d'une
certaine manière l'afrique se tire une
balle dans le pied diplomatique de par
sa dépendance vis-à-vis de l'ukraine la
russie dans ce domaine elle a une
dimension politique
cet échange il a une dimension politique
incomparablement vous avez vu comment
les français dans certains pays comme le
mali sont particulièrement mal vu et on
sait pourquoi il y a évidemment des
reproches éminent affaire à la présence
française mais plus généralement il ya
me semble-t-il une séquelle du complexe
coloniale c'est à dire que lorsque vous
avez l'ancien tutelle qui prend un parti
donc la france qui est pour l'ukraine il
convient dans certains africains d'être
radicalement opposées et donc de
soutenir la russie ce qui veut que
certaines ce qui veut dire que certaines
choses du complexe coloniale ne sont
toujours pas digéré et toujours pas
finalement surmonté c'est là l'un des
aspects de cette crise merci boîtier
pour le décryptage